ce travail essaie de sauver autant de personnes
que possible parfois cela ne veut pas dire
tout le monde mais tu n'abandonnes pas
New York Washington DC
sokovia
ok c'est assez capitaine les gens ont
peur
c'est pourquoi je suis ici
nous avons besoin d'être mis un chèque quoi que ce soit  forme
qui prend Je suis un jeu Je suis désolé Tony si je
vois une situation dirigée vers le sud Je ne peux pas l'
ignorer
parfois j'aimerais pouvoir parfois je
veux te frapper dans tes dents parfaites
Je sais que nous ne sommes pas parfaits
mais les plus sûrs  les mains sont toujours les nôtres
je me suis trompé sur toi le monde entier
s'est trompé sur toi ils viennent pour
toi je ne suis pas celui qui a besoin de surveiller
leurs arrières
ça ne doit pas finir par un combat Tony
tu viens de commencer un  war
stay down dernier avertissement je pourrais faire ça
toute la journée d'
accord je n'ai plus de patience
underoos hey tout le monde